(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 209 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
We continue with the Facebook
Live concept which means that
the questions will be coming in
the comment section India will
connect and you can see we have
a guest again which excites me.
India how are you doing?
- [India] Good.
- You just said right before
camera that you were excited
about the show and I said oh are
you really exactly and
then you said no, not really.
- I was just kidding 'cause I
said I was excited in a very
dull voice and it
sounded I wasn't excited.
- Got it.
That's just how you roll.
- Yeah.
- My man.
Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are--
- Yes.
- and then we'll
get into the show.
And India just informed me
you're going to as the first
question which excites me.
So I'm ready to go.
It's a good day.
Staphon drilled, Staphon can you
zoom in here if you can get it.
Staphon elbowed me
today in basketball so
I continue to be injured.
Luckily I was traveling 'cause
the black eye got really bad.
Do you got it?
- [Staphon] I got it.
- Alright so it hurts.
- [Staphon] It was an accident.
- You get way more
injured in your world.
- I try not to.
- Have you ever
really been injured?
- I've had a concussion which I
think is probably as bad as an
injury as you'd want.
But nothing major.
I'm a NASCAR driver.
My name is Landon Cassill.
I drive the number 38 car in
the NASCAR Sprint cup series.
- That's a big deal.
- That's my life.
- It's crazy.
- Yeah.
- Before we get into the show
what about two minutes on that.
Where were you born?
It's funny with NASCAR I always
think that you have to be in the
game when you're five
or six or seven to get
to that kind of level.
Is that true?
Did you drive at an early age?
- Yeah, I think so.
- Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Iowa.
I'm from Cedar Rapids, Iowa.
I think in anything you have
to get your 10,000 hours in.
- Malcolm Gladwell theory.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Okay.
- I just lived and
breathed racing.
But I grew up in a car business
was so I was kinda around it.
Dad and uncle gearheads.
We love cars.
Started out in
go-karts and just live for it.
In high school, I didn't
really go to any school dances.
I worked on my
racecars every day.
- Yep.
- I raced my senior
year of high school
I raced in over 70 races
across the country.
- Did by that time you
understand that you were capable
of being a NASCAR driver?
- I think it was age 15, 16
is when so like prior to 15, 16 it
was what I wanted to do and I
just I was young and stupid and
just knew I was going to do it.
I didn't know how.
- Right.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I was just doing it.
- I would work on my car every
single day I traveled and raced
two, three times a
week and that was it.
I just knew somehow that I was
going to be a NASCAR driver.
And it became real when I
was 15, 16 and I was actually
getting national media
attention in the racing world.
I had signed with an agent
when I was 15 years old.
And I actually had manufacturers
approaching me at the time
to come test for them to
see what I was capable of.
So when I was 16 I did
a test was Chevrolet and
I got signed through that.
And it was a test with a bunch
of different drivers in it who
eventually Ray was a part of
this test, Indy 500 champion
there were some legit drivers in
this deal and I came out towards
the top of this test I got
a contract from Hendrick
Motorsports which
is a powerhouse.
- Yep.
- And I was Jimmy Johnson's
test driver for five years.
Going straight
out of high school.
And that's what launched my
professional career as a driver.
So during that five years
I raced like part-time in the
NASCAR Xfinity series.
I won the rookie of the year
which is kind of like the second
level to the Sprint Cup series.
And that kind of built my resume
testing for Hendrick that in the
industry even though I wasn't
racing full-time it built a
resume for me that teams looked
at me and they're like we know
this guy's driving good cars,
he knows how to drive them.
And I started to get
opportunities with small teams
that were underfunded that
were in a shortage of drivers.
- Yeah.
- So yeah I got opportunities to
drive for the small teams and
since then I've just kind
of been working my way up.
- How long have you
been in the Sprint series?
- So my first start was 2010.
- Got it.
- Six years going on six years.
And this is my--
- So how did you end up here?
You and India are best friends?
- Yeah. Social media.
- Snapchat.
- Social media friends.
- How did the show or how to my
content first hit your radar?
- So I have a friend in
Charlotte his name is
Caleb Clark and he's a
fashion designer.
- Yep.
- He owns a brand
called Enemy To Fashion.
- Okay.
- And he's someone that I've
always looked up to on the
creative side of things.
He's just always ahead of the
curve when it comes to just
knowing what's going on.
- Yep.
- And when he introduced me,
introduced me to you I think
I realized what his secret is.
(laughter)
But really Caleb's been
around for a long time.
Him and I worked together.
He was at an agency
that represented me
when I was 15.
And he was the creative director
of and now he's an entrepreneur
and self-made man.
- Very good.
Alright so what is
the first question?
- Well in your world,
in social media and
marketing taking your
expertise and applying it
to my business model--
- Yes.
- which is athlete,
independent contractor because
I'm not represented
by a players union.
- Yes.
- I'm not presented
by the NFL or NBA.
I'm a NASCAR driver but
essentially I'm responsible for
my own brand.
I'm responsible for
my own revenues--
- And the revenue comes in
with the logos on the car?
- Yep.
- And then appearance fees.
- And anything else?
- Performance on the track.
Now logos on the car improve
the performance on the track.
- And vice versa?
- Absolutely.
- Right. Chicken and egg game.
- Exactly.
- So the question is what
would I do if I were you?
- How do we, how do
I create a better--
- Platform?
- platform, a value proposition
for corporate partners?
- I 100% believe that you
should execute
the DailyVee execution.
I think there's an enormous
amount of people who are
watching right now.
NASCAR is a humongous religion.
I didn't say sport.
It's a humongous,
humongous religion.
- Amen.
- And I believe that there are
hundreds of thousands of people
that would watch your
17 to 22 minute vlog.
As a matter of fact, let's,
you know, we haven't
really done this yet.
This is a good opportunity to
do what I'm about to do, this.
In the comment section on
Facebook and YouTube if you are
what you call your guy's
self Staphon, videographer?
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- Great.
If you're an aspiring
videographer,
sorry I mean I don't
know everything.
I know my thing.
If you are aspiring and you're
young and you're a hustler and I
would assume this would probably
make even more sense maybe this
is not exactly how it ends up
happening but you love NASCAR.
I would tell you I'm kinda
jumping to conclusions you might
not want to human being
following you around 24 hours a
day with a camera but I truly
believe that what we're doing
with DailyVee right now is very
much no different than what
I did in 1996 by doing e-commerce.
Or what I did by doing a
YouTube show back in 2006.
That this television-like
content, vlogging and Casey and
many other people
did it before I did.
I think what the hard-core day
in the life version of it though
is quite powerful.
The number one thing I would do.
I truly believe that and it's
funny that you're sitting here.
I would almost even use this
as an analogy but I'll use a
different one without you
sitting here but refers to where
you sit in the NASCAR world.
I think the 10th man on
an NBA team right now
to execute this model
would fundamentally
be one of the five
most popular players
in the NBA in three years if he
had the right personality and
was a good guy and had the
right, it's just storytelling.
The hell is Kim Kardashian?
Right?
- Just storytelling. Yeah.
- It's a story of that world.
Every reality TV star,
it's just storytelling.
And I think that's
what you should do.
I think it's very
black and white.
I'm very proud that
I'm creating a blueprint that
I think is replicable.
And I think that's
what you should do.
- I appreciate it.
I love that.
- I think it would
change your world.
- I think you're right.
I think you're right.
I'll double down on that.
- And the biggest thing that you
need to figure out is is what
access they have.
I assume a lot.
I've been to Poconos.
That's where you're going?
- Yeah, yeah. Next weekend.
- My father-in-law was the
marketing guy that did the
Gillette Young Guns
years and years ago.
People are filming
there all the time.
As long as somebody can have the
right access and it's the
real stories, right?
Everybody see
Sundays or Saturday.
What about Tuesday?
Stopping and driving
around the country.
That's the real stuff.
- Mhmmm.
There's a lot of content.
- You're going to double down?
- No I mean I--
- I like doubling down.
- No, I'll double down on that
because that's been on my mind.
- You think he's
very good at Snapchat.
This is the first...
- That was a huge hit.
That was really successful and
just like you said I just told
a story over the course of my
day where I'm saying I'll double
down on that is like you
said leave a comment,
find me somehow.
Let's make this happen.
- No, no. You're gonna
have to do a little bit of work.
- Well I'll do work.
Yes, yes, yes.
- No, no, it's very easy.
Actually we'll do the work for
you somebody here on this team
will send you the two links to
the Facebook and the YouTube and
there are hopefully 30 to 50
people in the comments
section saying me.
I can afford there's people now.
I'm sure.
I will follow you for free.
DRock did it for
free for a while.
I don't know what.
I can tell you for sure that if
you're lucky enough that you're
a young kid hustler that's
trying to get exposure for
access to being
behind-the-scenes in NASCAR
it's going to change your
career outcome, I think it's an
absolute barter exchange.
I'm not trying to get you guys
to do free work even though I do
it all the time
and believe in it.
I have no idea if you do have
the ability to pay something,
travel costs, this that and
the the other thing but that's
exactly what I would do.
And I would be so pumped to
watch SportsCenter
in 17 months
of the story of you that you did
this and to know it all started
right here, right now.
- You got it.
- No really.
I fully hey ESPN I fully expect
the first scene of the E 60 to
start right here right now.
(laughter)
Okay. India.
- I'll win next
year's Daytona 500--
- Well that's a different thing.
You do that I'll run to
Daytona and be like it was me.
I did that.
Alright, let's do it.
- [India] The
first one from Dana.
- Dana.
- The first one (inaudible)
this question because I know you
probably don't have
as much background.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I applaud NASCAR for really
stepping up their social media
game recently, in what areas do
you think they could improve or
suggest on them to improve?
- So what is your point of view
because you're right I don't
have as much context.
- I think it is--
- What's happening
with the top stars?
Top 10 guys right now, how
are there rolling in social?
Anybody in the top 10 crew?
Not that you want to
call out or knock on.
- I think they're doing good.
- Is it a conversation
with the driver?
Do you hear people
talking about it?
- Yeah, I mean in my opinion
the leader of the pack
is Dale Jr which he's--
- I remember that
from Mountain Dew,
we're on Mountain Dew from
four years ago I knew
it was in his world.
- That falls in his lap because
NASCAR gravitates towards him.
The fans love him.
- Course.
- But what I appreciate about
Dale Jr is I feel like he's got
smart people around him that
have taken advantage of that and
they have gotten him
very well educated on
how to be on Twitter
and getting into Instagram
and they've got
radio show and podcast.
And he's doing a really,
really, really good job.
- That's awesome.
- I feel like the challenges,
there's probably a group of
drivers that are just
from a generation that
just don't need to.
They've made their living
racing cars for a long time.
Their form of sponsor relations
is appearances--
- Television commercial.
- doing the same things
the last 20 years so for them to
adapt to Snapchat and Twitter,
I mean they're all on Twitter but
it's a matter of
what are you doing.
- Who's doing it?
Is them?
Duh, duh, duh.
- Yeah.
- And what about
NASCAR as a whole?
- I think NASCAR has taken a
very serious move at
social media recently.
Whether it's
like we talked
about the Snapchat.
I took over their Snapchat.
Their Snapchat story on the
race weekend is phenomenal.
I would love to see more during
the week and see what
else is going on.
I would even love to see
in the NASCAR offices
and things like that.
- I honestly think that's your
whitespace for your daily vlog
that you're about to do soon.
- Yep.
- I can't wait.
I fully expect it to be
live within two weeks.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- There's no reason to really.
There's plenty of
leads in there.
- Just gotta get my wife's
permission were good to go.
- That's fine.
What is your wife's name?
- Caitlin.
- Caitlin, please.
- [India] This one.
- Yep.
- From a different sport.
This guy's hair is awesome.
- I know right.
- [Computer] Gary, India, Landon,
I just had a quick question
what did you guys think
about the NCAA and their policy
that restricts athletes from
getting sponsorships.
and money essentially. I know
it's kind of a big issue for them.
- It's a real taboo issue.
- [Computer] Well they kind of
have a right seeing that they're
on the road 24/7 and these
coaches get paid
a bunch of money.
- I mean look everybody's got--
- [Computer] What you think
about their ethics and what
can a business decision is that?
Thank you very much
Gary, Landon, India.
- Yeah, how are you going to
integrate that into the episode
the video? You did it?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- You had it. Talent.
- [Andy] Soft copy of it.
- Talent, man.
- Talent.
So I think that,
look I think is
a hotbed issue.
I think plenty of people say
well they get their
school paid for.
Me personally, Gary, thinks
it's complete horseshit.
I think every college athlete
should be paid, period,
end of story.
I think the universities
exploit it aggressively.
It feels very communistic.
I'm not a fan of it.
I think that the athletes should
be paid and that's how
I feel about it.
Very simple.
Very, very binary.
But I think the taboo issue.
I have a lot of friends that get
mad at me when we drink a glass
of wine on this issue but they
get their college paid for and
this that and the other thing.
To me it is just economics.
They're making
drillions of dollars on
these kids performances.
These kids are being treated
like professional athletes.
These kids are
not going to class.
These guys are practicing 40,
the practice schedules of these
professional athletes especially
at the tiers where the TV deals
are men's college basketball,
women's college basketball,
men's college football,
softball on ESPN now.
They keep building
bigger and bigger schedules.
They're being treated like
professional athletes and
they're not being compensated
that way and an unbelievable
majority of them never make
it to the professional level.
And ever are able to cash in
on the dollars they dropped in
university so I think
they should be paid.
I'm pretty emotional about it
for them but it is what it is.
There's plenty of
things that upset me.
You have any thoughts on that?
- I don't know.
I don't think I agree with
you as binary as--
- Yeah.
- you describe it and
it's straightforward.
But I think I could
easily be weighted that way.
But I look at it as
university is primary
number one needs to be a
place of higher education.
I didn't go to college.
I wish I did.
- Yep.
- I'm fortunate that I get to
make my living that I'm actually
making a living driving.
- Yep.
- But it concerns me like if
they set up a way to start
paying football players the
effects of the 99% of them that
don't make it professionally and
what they did during their time
in college when they were
making $50,000 a year playing
professional college football
and not going to class because
they were making their living.
And now all of a
sudden they didn't make it.
You know, so I'm a little
worried some of
the problem there.
- The problem from my standpoint
that's a romantic point of view
because those same kids are
not going to class anyways.
They're not pumping out of the
University of Michigan and going
on to have these illustrious
careers because of
their education.
First of all I have my own
problems of college to begin
with, forget
professional athletes.
Person that goes to Michigan and
leaves with a degree reality in
today's marketplace is
a whole 'nother issue.
We don't have enough time for
this because I can get really
emotional about this.
- The thing that's absolutely
dead on that you're so right
about is the cornerstone of the
whole argument is they're
making hand over fist.
- Guys the SEC
contract with ESPN,
these rules were
implemented in a time when these
universities were not making
anywhere close to these dollars.
It's become, (speaking Russian)
it's a great Russian saying.
It's very basic.
It's like everything is
great when it's balanced.
From 1961 the amount of money
colleges were making on these
athletes were more in the
universe karma balance fairness.
Today?
You have a star player, do
you know how many Johnny Manzel
Texas A&amp;M jerseys were sold?
I mean forget it. Anyway.
- [India] I thought this
question was really cute
so I picked it.
- That's great India.
- It's from Thomas.
- Thomas.
- Aside from teaching money and
marketing tricks do you have any
regarding love?
Isn't that cute?
- Yeah, it's adorable.
- My advice on love is very
similar to my advice on,
I actually think
my business advice
is actually my life advice.
If you really unwind it.
I think 51/49 really matters
and that's more
relationship now than love.
I think that, I always say
the magic is in the gray.
I think that's how love is.
It is not calculated.
It's just going to happen in a
lot of times in a lot of ways.
I actually think all the advice
I give actually executes to a
love genre.
I think the relationship
part's more interesting to me.
The 51/49, the listening and
counterpunching, a lot of those
things the way I think
about customer and business
relationships are very much the
way I think of the
relationships in general.
That's how I've rolled.
As far as the falling in love
part, the serendipity, it's very
similar to the things I think
about business where you can't
control what you can't control
and don't be crippled by it.
That would probably
my biggest advice.
Got any love
advice married man?
- Yeah.
- How long have
you been married?
- Going on four years.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
You want someone
that'll just complement,
that's an addition to you.
My wife is
everything that I lack.
I'm being so romantic but
it's in so many ways it is the
cliché that
everybody says it is.
I look at my wife and she's
capable of so many things that
I am not capable of that
why I need her in my life.
- Sure. I married my mom.
- [India] Yeah.
- You married your mom?
- Yeah, my wife and my mom have
a lot, a lot of similarities
other than my wife is very
organized and structured
and my mom's not.
Other than that a lot of
their personalities are similar.
- [India] Interesting.
- Yeah.
- [India] They say a lot of
guys end up doing that,
marrying their mom.
- I think the mom is the North
Star for guys they go either
hard core to the
left or the right.
My dad married the anti-mom.
- [India] Maybe it's
again a generational thing.
Maybe it skips.
- It skips.
Alright, let's go India.
You have a cute question?
- No.
I like cute questions.
From GR, I don't
know his real name.
How do you feel that social
media has shaped NASCAR is a
good or bad as a driver or
good or bad as a fan also?
- So our entire business
model is supported by
corporate support.
- As is almost everybody's.
- Yeah, I guess that's true.
So you want to show
your personality
but you can't,
it's easy to second-guess your
personality if what if I have a
sponsor that isn't
going to like this.
- To your point,
it's even further.
Football players shows his
full personality in the contract
duh, duh, duh.
- Where I say our whole business
model is supported by corporate
support is because it takes
that to run the NASCAR team.
We can't survive just
off the prize money.
We have to have corporate
support or somebody has
underwrite the program.
- Yeah.
Is there in NASCAR is there
some billionaires that have
underwriting some programs?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
There's plenty of them.
And my team is,
our car owner is a racer.
He's not making
money off our race team.
- He loves it.
- He's a racer.
- He loves the game.
- And so we search hard
for sponsors because
it helps our team and
because we've got a passion
for the sport we want to
grow the sport want to grow our
partners but at the end of the
day my car owner, he steps up.
- At what percentage is it the
25% and down, actually in the
bottom third of like
financial teams--
- Yep.
- How much time do you think the
driver and the core two or three
top people spend
on the business part of
hustling for sponsors?
What percentage of time do you
spend on thinking about,
trying to secure doing
appearance, like hustling?
- Man, I mean I spend
every day thinking about it.
I struggle it's hard
to apply it sometimes.
I don't do enough,
I think too much.
I probably don't do enough.
I travel Thursday to Sunday.
By the time I'm can sit down in
my office can actually act on
thoughts and can do things I'm
on a plane and heading to the
racetrack where I have
to focus on the racecar.
- Right.
- There's definitely a struggle
of balancing and
executing, right.
That's where we talk about
content generation
and things like that.
Man, for me the struggle
isn't I guess what content
do I create, it's how
do I execute it?
- When a driver wins a big race
that's a bottom 20% financial,
like how rare is that?
- It's pretty rare but NASCAR
is really, they're changing the
rules in terms of how the cars
are built to help accommodate--
- More parity?
- More parity because--
- It's the greatest
thing the NFL did.
- Yeah, absolutely.
It's hard.
People don't realize how
much goes into the racecar.
And how many engineers it
takes and how many what adding,
finding a secret bend in your
body that adds 50 pounds of
down force, I can feel that.
That's this right here.
- Yeah.
- Pushing down on your car.
I can feel that in the
car, it makes me go faster.
Some of the big teams they're
just so much capable of finding
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten more of those things.
So people don't realize that
lack of parity is something that
NASCAR's very aware of that
they're trying to improve and
that's what helps
teams like mine.
At the end of the
day (inaudible).
- Do you have a
sponsorship person on your team?
- Yeah, oh yeah.
We've got a
marketing staff, yep.
- Very cool. Interesting stuff.
I enjoyed it.
Question of the
day you get to ask.
- Question of the
day, oh me ask.
- Yeah.
You get to ask the Vayner Nation
any question you want and they
have to answer it.
It's the rule.
- Alright.
If you were a NASCAR
fan at one point in your life
why aren't you now?
- Oh interesting, so you're
asking the small subgroup--
- Yeah, well the Vayner Nation
or the people that in
Vayner Nation that
know about NASCAR
let me widen it
out a little bit.
If you know about NASCAR--
- Why are you not currently,
why are you not currently a
NASCAR fan?
- Yeah, why are you not
engaged in that sport.
- Whether you once
was or whatever.
Have you ever watched NASCAR?
Don't worry.
No hurt feeling here.
- [Andy] Not really.
- Staphon?
- See not really that's
the guy I'm targeting.
Yeah, I've seen it on TV--
- Have you watched a full race?
Have you ever
watched a full race?
- [Andy] No.
- No.
- [Staphon] No.
- [Man] No.
- No.
- [DRock] One.
- One.
- [India] One.
- Got it.
Because we scheduled
the thing last week.
(laughter)
- It was a real pleasure.
- I appreciate it, man.
- Good luck to you.
You keep asking question
we'll keep answering them.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be down there.
It'll be down to your left.
- It's here down to my left.
Right here, there's
a button for them to
subscribe to my YouTube video?
Yeah it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.